most Americans agree that police
brutality and rioting are both wrong so
why are our political class in dining
Americans for the death of George Floyd
plus good news
apparently protesting racism means kovat
19 can't kill you things I didn't know
you're listening to the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected and expressvpn calm slash
Ben okay so while we watch the fire
raging it out of control and good news
was last night it seems like it raged a
little bit less out of control there
wasn't major rioting in Los Angeles
doesn't seem like there was as major
rioting in New York there are some
problems in New York but it wasn't
nearly as bad DC seems to have gotten
things more under control Minneapolis is
under control as well and you know why
that was because of all the evil
terrible police officers and law
enforcement officers who are apparently
systemically racist who are out there
protecting the veneer of civilization
from rioting and looting you know we
ought to recognize a couple things can
be true at once one police brutality is
bad second the police who you are
inciting a systemically racist and evil
are the people who are standing between
you and a smashed window they're the
people who are standing between you and
being beaten on the streets hey there is
a reality in the world that reality is
they're bad people who are willing to do
you harm and the people who are in blue
are very often the last line of defense
against those people and we saw that
over the past week that's not mean that
police brutality is OK it means that you
ought to actually be accurate in your
portrayal of the police instead of this
binary decision making where you see
people chanting things like abolish the
police abolish the police ain't going to
go so well if the last week was any
indicator ok so here is the thing that
that's super irritating about everything
that is going on I mean there are many
things that are very irritating about
everything that's going on the big
narrative that is supremely irritating
is the narrative that Americans broadly
speaking are responsible for the death
of George Floyd and this can be
attributed to a larger narrative which
is that America writ large is
responsible for every inequality that
exists in America that inequality is
inequity and that every inequality can
be laid at the feet of the American
system which is of course how you get
people justifying the looting of target
because the idea is by looting target I
am looting an institution of the
American hierarchy now normally we would
just say that if you mean
target your piece-of-crap but as long as
you cite these sort of Marxist pseudos
studies that they university professors
and members of our media spout as long
as you say that target is just an
institution of the capitalist structure
and therefore you break me into an ATM
is fighting back against the system that
oppresses you
well then apparently it is utterly and
totally fine now here's the thing about
all this this would assume that most
Americans didn't care about George Floyd
if you listened to our politicians it
really is incredibly listen to our
politicians and our media and many of
the protesters they're screaming to the
heavens that Americans don't care about
George Floyd weird cuz every single
person I have met ever knows George
Floyd's name and every single person I
have met ever believes that that police
officer should go to jail for putting
his knee on the neck of a man for nine
long minutes while he says I can't
breathe and provides no threat to the
officers I'm still waiting to meet the
people who think that the police officer
was completely fine but there is
widespread widespread agreement on
virtually all of these issues that the
fact is the vast majority of Americans I
mean like nearly all of them believe
that police brutality is bad and if you
look at these statistics on the protests
that are happening right now there is a
poll that is out from morning consult
and Monmouth and here's what it says
regardless of the actual actions taken
do you think the anger that led to these
protests was fully justified partially
justified or not at all justified fully
justified 57% of Americans say yes
partially justified 21 percent of
Americans say yes that means 78 percent
of Americans say that this thing was
either fully or partially justified only
18 percent say that it was not at all
justified and I'll go further than that
I think that the question is vaguely
worded I think that if you ask Americans
how many of you believe the police
brutality should be ended the answer
would not be 78 percent the answer would
be 99.99999%
also how many Americans believe that
their local police department is doing
good job forty-one percent of Americans
say that they are very satisfied with
their local police department thirty
percent of Americans say they are
somewhat satisfied with their Police
Department said 71 percent and another
13 percent say they are somewhat
satisfied and now or they're neither did
satisfied nor satisfied okay so that
means that doing some quick mental math
84 percent of Americans say they are
somewhere between
there okay and they're doing a great job
on their own police force
so does that suggest that people believe
that their police force is systemically
racist and that their police officers
are evil and terrible and no-good and
very bad also a clear majority of
Americans say they support supplementing
City police forces with the military in
order to stop riding rioting a very
large majority of Americans in fact 58
percent of Americans say they either
strongly support or somewhat support
sending in the military if necessary in
order to stop rioting just 19 percent
say they strongly oppose 11 percent say
they have no opinion now there is one
data point where Americans have shifted
so all of those stats by the way are
extremely consistent they've been very
consistent for a very long time
Americans like and respect police
officers in their neighborhood by and
large by statistics by poll statistics
Americans by and large like universally
think police brutality is bad and
Americans don't want to see rioting and
looting in their streets these seem like
things that we can all agree on right it
seems like a pretty good starting point
for a society and a civilization the one
area where opinion has shifted is in the
area of whether they believe that black
Americans are more likely to be victims
of excessive force than white Americans
in July 2016 when Barack Obama was
president that answer was 34 percent of
Americans said that black Americans were
more likely than white Americans to be
victims of excessive force if they are
black that was during Barack Obama's
presidency now Trump is president and
that number has skyrocketed to 57
percent I would suggest that the
partisan breakdown is that a lot more
Democrats than Republicans have now
shifted their opinions on this because
of the nature of the President of the
United States I think that has very
little to do with the underlying
feelings about all of this so if we all
basically agree on a lot of this stuff
then why the division and the answer
again goes back to this suggestion that
is being put forward by the media by our
politicians by academia by the political
class that the death of George Floyd is
supposed to be a referendum on you as a
person and you as an individual and on
America writ large and there we do have
some pretty significant and severe
disagreements it will get to those
disagreements in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that if you've
got a medical problem
like for example erectile dysfunction it
can be really difficult to talk about
that with a doctor I mean can be very
embarrassing and right now can you get
to a doctor's appointment anyway so why
not just get this
problem solved then you never have to
think about it again this is why you
should go check out my friends over at
Roman they've spent years building a
digital platform that can connect you
with a doctor licensed in your state all
from the comfort of home
just grab your phone or a computer
complete a free online visit you'll hear
back from a US licensed physician within
24 hours if the doctor decides that
treatment is right for you your
medication can be shipped directly to
your door with free two-day shipping
you'll also get free unlimited
follow-ups with your doctor anytime you
have questions or you want to adjust
your treatment plan with Roman there are
no commitments and you can cancel
anytime
so if you're struggling with eg stay
home or go to get Roman comm / Ben for a
free online visit in free two-day
shipping
let's get Roman comm /ban for that free
online visit and free two-day shipping
again if you got a medical problem
there's no reason to pretend that it's
not happening instead just go get it
solved and then you can make your life
better today get Roman comm / Ben for
that free online visit and free - free
two-day shipping GE TR o ma n com / Ben
alright so we're gonna get to the
narrative problem in just a second but
suffice it to say that the the narrative
dichotomy that's been set up by our
media by our political betters by the
elites in our society that political
narrative that America is bad and
terrible means that our political class
have gone incredibly soft on rioters and
looters
they've got incredibly soft on people
who are who are acting violently and
that has real-world consequences I mean
people are dying and I don't just mean
people who are victims of police
brutality we have seen a bevy of police
officers shot we have seen police
officers attacked we saw over the last
48 hours our retired st. Louis police
captain named David Doran who is black
we saw him shot to death outside of
eluded North City pawn shop in st. Louis
he's 77 years old he was a retired st.
Louis City captain according to the
ethical Society of police in st. Louis
Durham was retired at st. Louis at City
captain and they said he was murdered by
looters at a pawn shop he was the type
of brother that would have given his
life to save them if he had to violence
is not the answer whether it's a citizen
or an officer apparently he was murdered
during looting well exercising law
enforcement training according to st.
Louis Police Chief John Hayden the
videos absolutely heartbreaking
absolutely heartbreaking of a family
member standing over his body as the man
dies on the sidewalk but you you
wouldn't know David or his name
except for a few media stories we're
gonna have NASA nationwide protests over
George Floyd because apparently the
great threat to black Americans is the
police but this 77 year old retired
police captain who is black was murdered
and nobody's gonna know David Dorn's
name within 48 hours because that's the
way our media culture works in this
country just as nobody knows the name of
the federal officer the black federal
officer who was shot to death and
murdered in cold blood in Oakland
nobody's gonna remember his name either
because it doesn't fit the narrative the
narrative is that black people in
America are at existential threat
because of white people in America even
though that is not true it isn't true
and we're gonna get to how not true that
is in just one second so President Trump
of course tweeted about the the officer
who was shot and he tweeted out a
tribute to the officers at our highest
respect to the family of David Doran a
great police captain from st. Louis was
viciously shot and killed by despicable
looters last night we honor our police
officers perhaps more more than ever
before thank you and we should keep in
mind by the way that the police in the
vast majority of situations as in like
98% of situations are doing their best
and are not violating the law and yes
there are police officers who are brutal
and yes they're police officers who are
doing bad things and you can see videos
of them right now because if you expand
the number of police civilian
interactions the number of bad things on
a raw level is going to go up that's
just the reality of the situation but
officers like David Doran who again is a
retired police officer they matter to
they matter to I mean it this stuff is
just egregious the in New York City the
Bill DeBlasio who's the head of the
police department because in New York
City the mayor is the head of the police
department he's allowed the the NYPD
officers to basically they've been
abandoned they've been abandoned and
there's video of NYPD cars yesterday
that was that was going around and how
many of them had had their windows
shattered how many of them in spray
paint said we've seen this in LA as well
the abandonment of law enforcement is is
ongoing and insane and by the way the
andaman of civilians which we'll get to
in just one second but here is a list in
the last 96 hours of the the police
officers who have been who have been
attacked over the last 96 hours you
won't hear about any of this right
because again the story is only the
police officers are the bad guys and
that they are systematically attempting
to exterminate viciously brutalized
black Americans
even though the fact is that the people
that they are largely protecting from
crime in areas where they are having
encounters with black Americans or other
black Americans the police get called
when a black American calls the police
because another black American is trying
to hurt them just the same way the
police show up on a white american calls
because the white american is trying to
hurt them and the vast majority of crime
in the United States is intra-racial not
interracial the vast vast vast has vast
majority and by the way for gonna speak
about interracial crime there is vastly
more by percentages black on white crime
than there is white on black crime but
the bottom line here is that if we're
going to talk about what the police are
doing on a day to day level what we see
in the George Floyd case is not what the
police are doing on a day to day level
that is statistically aberrant it is
evil it is horrible that Officer should
go to jail
police brutality should be ended and by
the way there they're certain there are
certain policies that we should all be
able to agree on that the left won't
agree on five moments from now right
okay here are a couple of them we should
get rid of qualified immunity that means
that right now by 8 1982 Supreme Court
doctrine police officers if you are
acting outside the scope of your
authority if you violate so many civil
rights you're granted immunity by
Supreme Court doctrine that's ridiculous
just because you are you are in a blue
uniform does not mean that you get to
put your knee on the neck of a guy for
nine minutes while he well he asphyxiate
obviously and then there is the and then
there is the problem of police unions
public sector unions across the board
are a problem I'm one of the few
Americans right left or senator who's
been saying this for years police unions
fire fire unions teachers unions anybody
who's unionizing against the taxpayer
which is what public sector unions are
it's a problem because then presumably
you're gonna strike against the public
right that's what that's the always the
threat of the Union isn't gonna strike
and negotiating contracts with the city
that are not in the interest of the
civilian population is is pretty
ridiculous okay so those are some things
we could do right now is we could simply
say that police unions that public
sector unions broadly ought not exist
hey that is something that we that by
the way that was true for most of
American history and only became public
sector unions as important facets of
American life in the 1930s really on
late 1930s under FDR and under the
Wagner Act but those are things left
won't agree on in a moment because as
soon as we get down to specifics we
realize the left doesn't actually care
about the specifics for a lot of people
politically all they care about is the
broader message which we'll get to so in
the last 96 hours
here's what's happened to the police
officers who broadly speaking have been
maligned as racist and part of a
systemically discriminatory system a Las
Vegas metropolitan police officer shot
in the back of the head struggling with
a rioter an active shooter opened fire
on law enforcement at a Las Vegas
courthouse for st. Louis police officers
were shot by an active shooter a New
York police officer was struck by a
vehicle three Buffalo law enforcement
officers were struck by a vehicle in
front of a police station three
Davenport law enforcement officers were
ambushed and one was shot 132 officers
were injured in Chicago during a riot 9
Pittsburgh officers were injured by
objects during a riot several officers
in Rhode Island were injured during
riots an active shooter opened fire at
the Oakland Police Department two
officers were struck didn't struck in
head with projectiles in Santa Ana two
Richland officers were struck in
Virginia one officer was struck in the
head by a brick in Alban e4 Prince
William County police officer sustained
head injuries from projectiles seven
officers injured in Sacramento several
officers shot at and injured in
Lynchburg several Champaign police
officers injured three Oh Clawd police
officers injured 21 officers injured in
Salt Lake City at least 50 Secret
Service agents injured by Molotov
cocktails in Washington three Denver
police officers run over by vehicle 33
New York police officers injured during
riots six Athens police officers injured
during a protest to Capitol Police
officers injured during the riot in
Harrisburg 12 Las Vegas metropolitan
police officers injured during riots 21
Minneapolis law enforcement officers
injured in riots one Federal Protective
Services officers officer shot and
killed okay so is that word of you
mentioned like any of that any of that
or are we all supposed to just act as
though none of this has ever happened or
none of this is happening the police
officers who are on the streets are
being abandoned by a lot of the
political class again in defense of the
broader narrative which is the police
departments across the country are
systemically racist because America is
systemically racist and thus all
Americans are somehow guilty for the
death of George Floyd about which 99.99
American % of Americans agree that the
officer did that should go to jail now
we're gonna get to the the sergeants
benevolent association they put out a
statement that is pretty astonishing
yesterday in response to the abandonment
of the police force by Bill DeBlasio
who's just a disgrace
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about something nice
something nice that you can do for
Father's Day how about like a family
portrait now that sounds really
expensive it ends so you're gonna have
to go get like a personal painter to
come to your house and you're all gonna
have to stand there for three hours
while they paint you in a still life in
a that's not the way this works in
said what you need is paint your life I
know they're great because I have a
portrait from paint your life of my
family hanging above my mantel place in
my library right now you get a
professional hand-painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price it's a user-friendly
platform that lets you order a custom
made hand-painted portrait in less than
five minutes it's quick it's easy get a
hand-painted portrait in about three
weeks send any picture yourself your
children family a special place a
cherished pet or you can combine photos
it makes the perfect birthday
anniversary or Father's Day gift it's
meaningful it's personal it can be
cherished forever again I love the
portrait that we have hanging above our
mantelpiece it is a spectacular piece of
art and you can get one too at paint
your life calm there is no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded guaranteed and right now as
a limited time offer you get 20% off
your painting that is correct 20% off
and free shipping to get the special
offer text the word been 264 thousand
that's been to 64,000 again text my name
been to 64,000 paint your life celebrate
the moments that matter most this makes
a fantastic fantastic gift go check them
out right now paint your life calm text
been 264 thousand for the special deal
20% off and free shipping okay so the
sergeant's benevolence Association in
New York City has now come out just
ripping into Bill DeBlasio as well they
should by the way the the sergeant's
benevolence Association says dear fellow
sergeants and being inundated with calls
text messages and emails pleading for
help please know I'm reading each and
every correspondence I receive I want
each of you to know I'm very much aware
of everything that is occurring in our
city I know we are losing the city we
have no leadership no direction no plan
I know you are being held back and used
as pawns I understand I am one of you I
am doing it and will continue to do
everything I can to protect you and the
people of the city so I'm asking you to
please stay together and stay strong
hold the line
protect each other stand
shoulder-to-shoulder do not give up
never give up I hear you I'm aware and
soon everyone is going to hear you help
is coming
we will win this war in New York City
remember you work for a higher authority
it's good against evil and good always
wins you talking about the looters and
the rioters not the protesters obviously
the following are some of the messages I
am receiving this is going to Ed Mullins
the president of the sergeant's
benevolence association total nightmare
last night the executives of the NYPD
are gonna get a member of the service
killed they have no plan set in motion
you have inspectors and Chiefs running
around the city with no direction leave
the police work to the frontline
supervisors I've been at these right
since the beginning I've been hit with
the eggs bricks and rocks my officers
are depleted tired and beat up our
officers and supervisors are getting
hurt every night doing their jobs not
any support from our PC our Chief of
Police and our mayor hey and this by the
way is is the widespread sentiment for
police officers in areas across the
country I'm talking to police officers
and major cities across the country
again because our pal our political
class is invested in a particular
narrative and that narrative is that the
violence and the looting and the
treatment of police officers is an
outgrowth it's a response to the the
evils of our entire system that's the
idea here
so it comes first and foremost from the
media so our media who are all Ivy
League educated college-educated
intelligentsia
who never are going to have to actually
be in the middle of one of these riots
ever right they get to sit in their push
mansions in in Upper West Side New York
they'd have to worry about their small
store being looted in Van Nuys they
don't have to worry about their
storefront windows being shattered in
the middle of Midtown so they can sit in
their in their studios and they can do
hits on CNN Nicole Hannah Jones the New
York Times editor who just want to peel
it surprise just wanna peel it surprise
for her 16:19 project which again is a
bag of garbage she said she was on CBS
News last night and she says it's
actually not violent to loot good news
guys it turns out Nicole Hannah Jones
has some orders about violence violence
because you know it turns out that real
violence is what's been done to black
people over over American history real
violence doesn't involve like burning
thing involve burning things down or
breaking into stores or anything like
that real violence is is just like is
just systemic racism according to Nicole
Hannah Jones now it turns out Jim Crow
is real violence so is so is slavery
those are real about you know what else
is real violence burning down a black
store owners store or a white store on
their store by the way I have some notes
in a few moments about the store owners
who are posting BLM messages on the
plywood outside their stores and in a
vain attempt to get the rioters and
looters to leave them alone but here is
Nicole Hannah Jones last night again
this is this commentary is so stupid she
should be given another Pulitzer here
she was explaining that violence does
not include looting and rioting it is
disturbing to see property being
destroyed it is disturbing to see people
taking property from stores but these
are things
violence is when an agent of the state
kneels on a man's neck until all of the
life is leached out of his body
destroying property which can be
replaced is not violence and to put
those things to use the exact same
language to describe those two things I
think really it's not it's not moral to
do that Oh weird because you know what
I've heard over and over and over from
members of the intelligentsia left is
that speech is violence hate speech is
violence using the wrong pronoun is
violence but apparently burning down
someone's store is not violence pretty
incredible stuff right there by the way
is it violence when people attack police
officers or shoot police officers or run
police officer officers over in cars is
that not violence are we not allowed to
comment on that either Chris Cuomo last
night was defending the riot or he said
what who says that rioters have to be
polite and peaceful then later says I'm
not approving of violence then why did
you use the word peaceful here's Chris
Cuomo last night too many see the
protests as the problem no the problem
is what forced your fellow citizens to
take to the streets persistent and
poisonous inequities and injustice and
please show me where it says that
protests are supposed to be polite and
peaceful because I can show you that
outraged citizens are the ones who have
made America what she is and led to any
major milestones be honest this is not a
tranquil time by the way peaceful
protests are usually the stuff that
actually affects change it is actually
if you want to affect political change
the last thing you should do is riot it
turns out that Richard Nixon probably
won election in 1968 on the back of the
rioting of 1968 if you actually want
people elected to oppose your agenda
bye-bye by all means go ahead and write
and burn crap down because you know what
that's doing it's leaving large
majorities of Americans to want the
military sent in to the cities to stop
all of this which doesn't sound anti law
enforcement to me so much but it wasn't
just Chris Cuomo block of wood Chris
Cuomo it was members of the media all
over who are defending the rioters the
immediate Research Center cut this this
little compendium of various members of
the media defending the writing many of
these protests have been largely
peaceful mostly
peaceful mostly peaceful mostly peaceful
I'm looking at those live pictures next
you and they seem very peaceful there
are always folks on the fringes of
protests that do the things that we
don't we don't like a few people who
break a few windows and burn a few cars
no one should be destructing property
and that sort of thing but I understand
the anger okay this was the narrative
from the media by the way you would
never hear anything remotely like this
for a cause the median in love and then
the media loved this particular cause
again it ties into the narrative we're
gonna gets in the narrative and the
falsehood of the narrative in just one
second but there is nobody who if this
were a tea party protest and swathes of
the tea party were going out and looting
and rioting if this were a an anti
lockdown protests and squads of people
were going I mean they weren't they were
going nuts and calling the protesters
violent for exercising their right to
bear arms and breathing too close to
other people now you have people who are
attacking cops and burning down we had
curfew in a County of 10 million people
in Los Angeles last night for like the
fourth straight night visit are you
insane but this is this is the narrative
the media are pushing so we're gonna
gets that narrative in just one second
because the narrative is a lie you are
not guilty for George Floyd's death
unless you are Derek Shelvin you are not
guilty for systemic racism unless you
have done a racist thing we're gonna get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about something calmer something
nice or something great for Father's Day
I am talking about the best steaks money
can buy him talk about Omaha Steaks I
mean these things are just spectacular
they sent me some kosher Omaha Steaks ah
heaven heaven in a bundle just
unbelievable stuff Omaha's world-famous
steaks they've been naturally aged at
least 21 days for tenderness hand-carved
to perfection now for tasty easy to make
side dishes artisan desserts and much
much more
Omaha Steaks has been America's original
butcher since 1917 they deliver a
guaranteed quality and safety with every
single order all backed by an
unconditional 100% money-back guarantee
every Omaha Steaks order is flash-frozen
vacuum sealed safely delivered in a
cooler with dry ice that means fresh so
if you are looking for a perfect
Father's Day gift I'm telling you the
packages that are available at Omaha
Steaks these are unbelievable dad is
never gonna be happier than when he
opens up a box and he sees the meats
from Omaha Steaks cuz this is amazing
amazing stuff right now
one maja steaks is offering my listeners
access to a variety of amazing packages
that are perfect to send for Father's
Day go to Omaha Steaks com
enter the coach Shapiro into the search
part to unlock savings for my listeners
a 50% and more and free shipping on
orders over 99 bucks there are lots of
packages available they're all ready to
be shipped straight to his door in time
for Father's Day or to your door if you
just feel like rolling it up in the
backyard go to Omaha Steaks comm and
enter the code Shapiro that's Omaha
Steaks calm enter code Shapiro to shop
for Father's Day today again all you
have to do is go to oh ma ha stay calm
go to that search bar and enter the code
Shapiro to look for these magical
magical packages is excellent excellent
stuff ok so what does the what does this
narrative that I've been talking about
and I'm gonna get to in a second lead to
the narrative leads to the bizarre
situation where if you defend your own
property we're now going to declare you
a vigilante this is what happened in
Philadelphia last night according to
townhall comm Philadelphia Mayor Jim
Kenney and police commissioner daniel
outlaw paid lip service to the right of
citizens to defend their businesses and
lives on Tuesday during a press
conference but the next breath they
expressed how to sturb they were that
people would take matters into their own
hands because it turns out when the
police won't defend you people tend to
defend themselves here's what happened a
gun store owner in the city shot and
killed a looter his 67 year old gun
store owner told cops he spent the night
at firing line Inc on South Front Street
after a recent attempted burglary at his
business he was inside his gun shop
overnight because someone had attempted
to break in over the past few days the
owner Greg Isabella
opened fire with a Bushmaster m4 rifle
according to police why well because a
group of four men using bolt cutters cut
a lock before forcing open a door to the
gun range about 4:15 a.m. the suspects
then proceeded to a second floor and
that's where Isabella was waiting for
them one of the male's pointed a gun at
the owner that's when the owner of the
gun shop was in possession of one of his
guns fired several shots striking one
male at least one time in the head so
what exactly did the politicians have to
say outlaw said we do not endorse or
condone any form of vigilante justice or
taking the law into one's own hands she
encouraged people to use safe nonviolent
methods when possible she was forced to
admit that there are very clear laws
that allow us to protect ourselves and
our property from harm Kenny said he was
deeply troubled by the incident what is
troubling about a man the only thing
that's troubling there is that somebody
was telling me to break into a store you
break into a store and you get shot for
your trouble that's a good thing but
again this ties into the narrative that
breaking it into stores rioting looting
all this ties into the bottom line
narrative in America is cruel
and America is evil and America is bad
and this has become a bipartisan
narrative so started off as a narrative
in academia on the left and now it has
made its way into conciliatory
Republican circles there are a lot of
there are a lot of conciliatory
Republicans who are trying to understand
the anger that they are seeing out there
and instead of saying okay well the
anger about police brutality is
justified the anger that suggests that
America is to blame broadly speaking for
instances like what we saw George Floyd
that is not justified that sometimes
anger is not actually justified and
certain types of anger may be justified
in certain types of anger it may not be
justified and we all feel this way in
our lives that there are certain types
of anger that are justified and certain
that or not but just because somebody's
angry anger is not self justifying you
have to provide evidence they are anger
is rooted in something that is true okay
but that apparently is gone by the
wayside so this has been a longtime
Democratic narrative is that America is
deeply racist and deeply sexist and
bigoted rooted in racism that America's
history began 1619 with the importation
of African slaves to the American
continent that it did not begin in 1776
in freedom and liberty what the American
story is truly about the exploitation of
black Americans by white Americans and
that has never let up it has it has it
has minimized slightly but not really
right that's been the narrative of the
left for a very long time and thus all
inequalities can be chalked up to
Americas in a evil and even if you're
not racist even if you've never done a
thing that's racist you're a product of
that racist system and therefore you
argue you are just as guilty as Derek
Shelvin for what happened to George
Floyd because you looked the other way
you were complicit in the system this is
the broad scale narrative that's being
driven this is what Joe Biden was doing
yesterday when he spoke in Philadelphia
so joe biden gave a speech from
teleprompter and congratulations to him
he got through three sentences without
falling all over himself so that's it
that's a big accomplishment for a man
who's on the verge of senility here was
Joe Biden the former vice president who
for eight years apparently had nothing
to say about about any of this stuff
except to rip police every so often
didn't solve the problem after 36 years
in the Senate but here he is now
explaining that we've all turned away
from inequality which again I'm gonna
need the evidence considering that
everyone agrees that the officer in the
George Floyd case should go to jail and
that when officers are brutal they
should go to jail we all agree on this
but here is Joe Biden laying George
Floyd's death at the feet of all of us
and you know what I'm not going to
accept collective responsibility for
some
I didn't do any more than a black
American should accept a collective
responsibility for rioting and looting
because that's bullcrap it's nonsense
we're individuals we should treat each
other as individuals here is Joe Biden
saying we should not I can't leave this
woman thinking that we can once again
turn away and do nothing I can't do that
this time
we just can't the moment has come for
our nation to deal with systemic racism
to do with the growing economic inequity
that exists in our nation to deal with
the denial of the promise of this nation
okay so he's just fulfilling the promise
laid out by LBJ back in the 1960s
suggesting that you don't have to
identify an actual inequity you don't
have to identify a difference in law you
don't have to identify an actual racist
all you have to do is say that when
something happens that is unequal that
is an indicator that America writ large
is broadly guilty right all inequality
is inequity that is the message here
this is a message being put forth by
Eric Garcetti our idiot mayor of Los
Angeles by the way can I just point out
that it is a bad thing to bring
thousands of people to protest out of
somebody's private right outside of
somebody's private residence protestors
room were being praised for this they
went outside mayor Eric Garcetti --zz
house I am NOT a Garcetti sympathizer
his kids are inside there that's where
his wife and his kids live protesting
outside somebody's house he's got an
office it's downtown you just go right
down there and protest it but going into
a residential area and then sitting
thousands of people sitting outside a
private residence because you don't like
Eric Garcetti is can we point out kind
of threatening like a little bit
threatening it's right outside how would
you feel if somebody were right outside
your door yelling at you would that feel
the same as if someone was protesting
outside your office I think not anyway
here is Eric Garcetti who went out into
the crowd again no masks or anything
we'll get to that in a second amazing
amazing how our politicians we all got a
lockdown you're killing grandma if you
don't wear a mask a hundred feet away
from everybody else but if you're
protesting against racial inequality
that's totally different than if you
want to just go back to work or
something or you want to go to synagogue
or something I'll get to that in a
little bit but here is Eric Garcetti
saying we need a country that listens
question you're the mayor how's that
listening going what does that actually
look like I'm so efficient to do this
all the time by the way I don't have a
listening tour well listening tour all a
tour where you use your ears well
problem solved guys
well listening tour just means I'm not
going to change anything but I'm going
to express my sympathy for your feelings
we're not going to address the core
issues and whether you are justified in
your feelings and whether there's any
data to back this and practical measures
to alleviate some of the problems
instead we're gonna go on a listening
tour and you know I'm sympathetic
because Eric Carr said he feels your
pain here's Eric Garcetti that's so
disgusting a black face should not be a
reason to die a reason to be
underemployed who's saying it should be
who are you arguing with Corey but like
really what are you arguing with and the
answer is they are arguing with nobody
you argue with nobody you're arguing
with a straw man in America that says
that black people should simply die what
is the statistical evidence that anyone
in America believes this but this of
course is the narrative that is said
because once the narrative is set
there's a predictable result and that
predictable result is unrest it is
because once you declare that America is
rotten root and branch
once you declare that a merit the
foundations of America are fundamentally
rotten you cannot then suggest well what
we need to do is we need to do a little
touch-up job right here you know unlike
the corner of the building once the
foundations of the building are
completely rotten there's only with only
one solution which is to destroy the
building and you can see that many of
the rioters and looters and yes the
protesters some of the protesters by the
way to pretend that that all the
protesters are unsympathetic to the
rioting and the looting is not true
there are some protesters who are very
sympathetic we haven't done polls of the
protesters it is not zero percent it may
not be 50 percent
it may not be forty but I don't know the
percentages you don't either but to
pretend is the media have done that all
the protesters are unsympathetic to the
looting is simply not true especially
when a lot of these a lot of the rioting
and looting is springing out from the
protests they started the protests and
the idea there outside infiltrators the
data are not too certain on that it is
not blaming all protesters writ large
for the actions of rioters and looters
but Amy Horowitz documentarian he went
to Minneapolis yes really asked some of
the protesters not the rioters and
looters
some of the protesters how they felt
about the rioting in the looting
and here was their explanation riding
and looting are justified because
America is evil because target is part
of the system here is ami talking to
some of the protesters who are
african-american hey man okay if you if
you push the narrative in America is
rooted in exploitation and slavery and
Jim Crow if you push the narrative that
all of today's inequality is driven by
yesterday's injustice Azure today's
continuing racism then is it a surprise
when people rebel against that is that
really a surprise the answer of course
is no and this is why it's a mistake to
give credence to the nerve in the first
place and I think the George W Bush gave
credence to the narrative yesterday I'm
really disappointed in him because it is
one thing to express sympathy for people
who are protesting police brutality I'll
go out there and protest members of the
police will go out there and protest
police brutality they were they took a
need they were marching with protesters
against police brutality but I'm
certainly not going to march with people
who suggest that Americans writ large
are responsible for individual actions
that are bad racist or evil that's crap
and to back that narrative is to
basically suggest that the entire system
needs to be torn away it doesn't create
unity it creates division we're gonna
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about the second memory you
know it's kind of important these days
of the Second Amendment you know how we
know because when the police are told by
the politicians not to step in and
protect you you might need a gun to
protect yourself
it's amazing to gun control laws they're
gonna be in a lot of they're gonna be a
lot of danger after what we just saw
over the prior week our founding fathers
knew you needed the ability to protect
yourself and the violation of your
rights from others because guess what
sometimes the police ain't gonna show
and this is why the people of Bravo
Company manufacturing take gun
manufacturing incredibly seriously the
people of Bravo Company MFG support the
right of responsible private individuals
to have the access and ability to employ
the same tools as civilian law
enforcement as a means of defending
ourselves our loved ones our communities
our freedoms should a threatening
situation ever arise BCM assumes that
when rifle
their shop it will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or
soldier overseas so quality is of the
utmost value to them every components of
a BCM rifle is hand assembled and tested
by Americans in Heartland Wisconsin to a
life-saving standard every American is
responsible to question debate confronts
issues that affect our lives and when
your life and liberty are threatened you
gotta protect yourself this is why you
need a firearm if the last week didn't
teach you that is a private citizen you
might need a firearm I don't know what
would go check out my friends at Bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
Bravo Company MFG comm where you can
discover more about their products
special offers upcoming news as Bravo
Company MFG comm if you need more
convincing find out even more about BCM
and the amazing people who make their
products at youtube.com slash bravo
company USA that's youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA alright we're gonna
get to George W Bush a statement which i
think is really not good and i think
that it buys into a particular set of
lies and then we're gonna get into the
pathetic attempt by some Americans to
basically avoid the rage of the of the
mob by essentially parried parroting a
line that is not true what gets you all
of that in a second that we have a lot
more to get to but you're gonna have to
go over to daily wire comma and
subscribe right now when you do you get
to count them to left just hears
tumblers ooh
the all-access membership it's our best
it's here why well you get to
participate in all exits live which is
great I'll access live is where I hang
out with you I answer your specific
questions I wear t-shirts which of
course is the big pitch all access
members also get to join us for
real-time Q&A discussions available on
both the website and the daily wire app
all access membership includes two of
those tumblers finally all access
members get all the benefits of all the
other memberships years including an ADD
free website experience access to all of
our live broadcasts and show library
access to the shows mailbags the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
along with dedicated editorials from moi
so head on over to daily wire comm /
subscribe join all access get 15% off
with coupon code Shapiro right now
that's daily wire.com slash subscribe
and we'll see you there you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
hey so the narrative again is America is
evil America hasn't listened America is
every inequality in America is due to
inequity this comes out in stupidest
possible fashion in a column by a person
named Subala trebs in ski the executive
director of the center for social
justice at the UC Berkeley School of Law
is a book about race gender and the body
published by Simon & Schuster in 2021
I'm sure it will be a massive bestseller
it is called black and brown people have
been protesting for centuries it's white
people who are responsible for what
happens next what I love about that
title particularly is the idea that
white people had nothing to do with you
know ending slavery white people had
nothing to do with ending Jim Crow that
basically there's this stark dichotomy
between the races which of course is not
true in terms of there are lots of good
white people and lots of bad white
people there are lots of great black
people and lots of bad black people it
turns out that individuals are both good
and bad this is a thing that happens but
according to this article at Time
magazine the way that you know you're
white is that you exist in opposition to
other groups she says how do you know
you're white I'm talking to one hundred
law students the room is racially
diverse and full of people who have
gotten into top law schools they're
committed to making racial equality a
cornerstone of their work they tend to
think about race in their daily lives
they've chosen to attend this evening
lecture about the problematic ways race
is baked into American law and legal
pedagogy but not a single hand goes up
to answer my question and this matters
you know why no one raised their hand
because they're afraid you're gonna yell
at them because if you say I know I'm
white because of the color of my skin
I'm gonna say no you're not you're not
acknowledging these systems and
hierarchies of race that have made you
that have made you so powerful and if
you say I don't think of myself is white
I think of myself as Jewish as well you
don't understand that you are white
because the systems of privilege and
power right no matter what you say
there's no right answer there's no right
answer according to this professor over
at UC Berkeley School of Law the way
that you know you're white in the end is
because you are a part of whiteness
right so you should be guilty because
you're white she says white students
often stop short unable to identify and
articulate the cultural political
economic and historic lose that's held
them they are part of whiteness let
alone what being part of whiteness truly
means I let the silence grow it gets
uncomfortable then I step in to suggest
that this phenomenon is a significant
part of America's problem with race if
you answer she yells at you because you
don't understand your own whiteness
unless you shout that you are guilty for
all of America's problems and then
if you do it and then if you don't
answer that's also the problem so this
particular narrative is is the end point
of the academic nonsense that suggests
collective responsibility for individual
sins and it's pretty disgusting because
so George Adobe Bush put out a statement
yesterday about the protests and he
bought into some of the nostrils that
have been promoted here now he starts
off and he talks about the the brutal
suffocation of George Flint again we all
agree then he says we have resisted the
urge to speak out because this is not
the time for us to lecture it is time
for us to listen it is time for America
to examine our tragic failures and as we
do we will also see some of our
redeeming strengths okay what what are
our tragic of failures it remains a
shocking failure than many African
Americans especially young
african-american men are harassed and
threatened in their own country ok can
we have some like data on that were some
specific people who are doing that
because that's a crime can we have so
this is just george w bush trying to
calm the anger it's the same thing as
police officers taking a knee with
protesters it's not the police officers
believe that they themselves are
systemically racist or or that they are
racist at all as the police officers are
trying to quell the anger by
legitimizing the anger there's a problem
however i understand the short term
strategy but there's a problem when you
legitimize the anger by also
legitimizing a lie namely that america
is in a horrible terrible place for
black americans to live that at black
americans cannot experience equality
that black americans are innately under
the thumb of white america there are
going to be predictable results that do
not end up working inside the political
system so george w bush puts out this
statement along with laura bush he says
this tragedy and a lot of similar
tragedies raised along over the question
how do we end systemic racism in our
society the only way to see ourselves in
a true light is to listen to the voices
of so many who are hurting and grieving
those who set out to silence those
voices do not understand the meaning of
America or how it becomes a better place
not sure who's trying to silence the
voices but are we allowed to say that if
you suggest that America is a
systemically racist place that any
evidence whatsoever of actual policy
that maybe you need to provide some
evidence that's not silencing that's
asking for evidence again anger is not
evidence and anecdotal evidence is a
form of evidence but it is not
statistical evidence the the buying into
the narrative that America broadly
Rett is is guilty for the sins of people
like Derrick Alvin that every one of
those instances can be broadened out and
blamed on American hierarchies of power
is a trope that has a predictable end
point and the predictable end point is
that is the disintegration of the
country that is the predictable end
point when you see people as a as a
member of a group everyone is a member
of a group that is either guilty or
innocent the only way you can expiate
your guilt by the way is by posting some
sort of black box on your twitter or
instagram that's how you don't that's
how you do your sacrifice in the temple
to to expiate your sins so you get
forgiveness this is not the way that a
country comes together this is the way a
country falls apart by holding people
accountable for things they did not do
and for holding the system accountable
for laws that no longer exist if you're
gonna talk about systemic racism they're
really only a couple ways to define
systemic racism one is practices and
laws that are innately discriminatory
Jim Crow housing bias right the things
that are innately discriminatory we all
oppose them and they're against federal
law hey then there is a second way to
define systemic discrimination and that
is disparate impact disparate impact is
the idea that if you pass a law and has
a disparate impact on one group in one
group is harder hit than another group
that this is an element of racism I do
not I will not endorse that version of
systemic racism because every single law
that has ever been passed in human
history impacts groups differently the
question is whether the law is directed
at the group but you see the conflation
right the conflation is okay if black
americans by and large are poorer than
white Americans then that must be
because of systemic racism we can't look
at any of the other factors if more
black Americans on a population level
adjusted basis are shot by the police
than white Americans then we immediately
have to announce that this is an aspect
of American races we can't look to any
other factor the simple inequality is
the inequity the fact that it is that
that group statistics are not identical
across groups is evidence that the
system is discriminating in favor of
certain people against other people
perfect example of this sort of bizarre
and unfounded logic today in the new
york times minneapolis police use force
against black people at seven times the
rate of whites okay now the first
question for anybody who sees that
headline is okay so why are the
minneapolis
Minneapolis police encountering more
black criminals than white criminals and
are those based on actual phone calls
from people reporting crimes right
because let me give you another example
virtually all Americans who go to prison
for violent crimes are men virtually
none are women does that mean that the
system is unequal with regard to men and
women or does it mean that men are
committing more crimes than women in
terms of violent crimes when you want to
know that before you declared the system
innately inequitable innately
systemically discriminatory against men
the answer is of course you would so if
the question is how many people are
being shot by police the second question
should be okay and how many people
committed crimes because if you look at
the Washington Post database of how many
people in America were black and unarmed
and shot by police in 2019 is the
Washington Post database the answer in
2019 was nine if you want to talk about
the number of black Americans who were
shot who are unarmed and who are not
fleeing from police the answer is three
does that sound like the extermination
of black people across the country it
does not know we're in this New York
Times piece not a single place do they
actually talk about differential crime
rates by race now again that's not
racist it is not racist to point out
that there are differential crime
statistics any more than it is racist to
point out that there are differential
statistics when it turns that when it
turns to police officers shooting people
hey a statistic is a statistic
statistics are not racist they are just
statistics hey but but apparently if you
point out that it's proportionate share
of crime is committed by young black men
this is racist but if you point out that
a disproportionate share of young black
men are shot by police then this is woke
how about both of those are stats and
they are related stats but we're not
allowed to point that out we just have
to attribute the disparity the second is
Barry you're not the first the second
disparity we are supposed to attribute
to broad-scale American racism so we
have this long long article about the
evils of the Minneapolis police my
favorite quote in this is from David
Schultz professor at Hamlin University
in Saint Paul he says the disparities in
the use of force in Minneapolis parallel
large racial gaps in vital measures in
the city like income education and
unemployment he says it just mirrors the
disparities with so many other things in
which Minneapolis comes in very badly
okay might it mirror the disparity in
crime statistics might it wouldn't that
be like the number one question
considering you called the cops this is
not about random white Americans
shooting random black men
is about the police who are called in to
deal with crime wouldn't you want to
know what the calls actually said before
you declare that the police are racist
if somebody calls up the police and says
you know my neighbor just murdered my
other neighbor both of them were black
and the police come and they get in an
armed confrontation with the person with
the murderer is that in a racist
incident or that the police doing their
job that's the big question the question
isn't how many black Americans are being
shot by police the question is how many
black Americans are being unjustifiably
shot by police and how does that compare
with the number of white Americans being
unjustifiably shot by police and more
because that would implicate racism and
more broadly how many Americans are
broadly being unjustifiably shot by
police is an issue of police brutality
okay and that when we all agree on but
instead we have to drive this narrative
over and over and over again that every
inequality is due to the the innate
evils of the United States and so you
saw CNN put up a piece today about
racial inequalities in the United States
in terms of the wealth gap it is true
that there are certain disparities in
the wealth gap that are attributed to
attributable to historic injustice is
like redlining for example because so
much of wealth is concentrated in home
ownership for example but it would not
explain racism would not explain the
continuing income disparity between
black Americans and white Americans
particularly because you know where
there is no income disparity if you look
at parental income if your parents are
poor you are not going to have as high
an income generally speaking after the
same period of time is somebody who's
born in a rich family which is not a
particularly surprise right you're gonna
grow up in a richer community you're
gonna have more connections that is a
class issue that is not a race issue but
if you are let's say that you're a black
woman who is born in a wealthy black
family versus a white woman born in a
wealthy white family how exactly does
that turn out is that racism well it
turns out there is no income gap between
black and white women race in similar
households none none it's only Moe males
which might implicate behavior because
it turns out that black women are also
black so again like statistics I know
I've been verboten here because we're
trying to drive a narrative it is wrong
for people to try and buy their way out
of conflict by buying into narratives
that are going to create deeper
conflicts over the nature of America
because again the idea that America
systemically racist and broadly racist
just allows people to number
avoid naming and shaming and and being
specific about policies and people who
are doing bad things and instead allows
them to say the entire system is guilty
therefore tear down the entire system
and if you don't say tear down the
entire system then you're a racist right
that is the that is the implication of
the narrative that is being drawn okay
in just a second I'm gonna get you some
actual police statistics and we'll talk
about systemic police racism we'll also
talk about this attempt to buy penance
particularly by woke white people who
are who are attempting to demonstrate
their bona fide ease by mouthing
platitudes which again does not care
racism you know didn't cure racism
you're putting up a black score in
Instagram yesterday racism not solved
you've accomplished zero things and
guess what it ain't gonna matter because
next time there's a police officer who
is white who kills a black man
unjustifiably nobody's gonna care they
put up a black square three years ago
no one ain't gonna matter one iota we're
gonna get to all this in just one second
first let's talk about the the actual
statistics so Heather McDonald who has
spent her life studying the statistics
on police brutality and racial
disparities she has a piece in The Wall
Street Journal that is worth reading
again we can acknowledge that people are
angry we can acknowledge that people
have anecdotal evidence of the police
mistreating them we can even acknowledge
that if you are a black person living in
a high crime area there is a better
chance that you had a bad run-in with a
police officer then there is if you are
a black person living in a high-income
area or if you're a white person living
in a high-income area or a white person
living in a low crime area right the
area is determinative and the amount of
interaction between police officers in
people of a particular race is
determinative - my guess is that you
could find quite a bit of anecdotal
evidence of police abusing Latinos in
East Los Angeles where there are high
crime rates and a lot of Hispanic
populations okay but here's Heather
McDonald talking about the the myth of
systemic police racism
she says this charge of systemic police
bias was wrong during the Obama years it
remains so today
however sickening the video of Floyd's
arrest it isn't representative of the
375 million annual context police
officers have with civilians a solid but
a solid body of evidence finds no
structural bias in the criminal justice
system with regard to arrests
prosecution or sentencing crime and
suspect behavior not race determine most
police actions in 2019 police officers
fatally shot one thousand four people
most of whom were armed or otherwise
dangerous African
Americans were about a quarter of those
killed by cops last year 235 a ratio
that has remained stable since 2015 okay
so first of all we should know just
right off the bat that police officers
fatally shot 235 black people last year
there are 30 million black Americans
that sound like a campaign of
extermination by police officers against
black people it does not that share of
black victims is less than what black
crime rates would predict since police
shootings are a function of how often
officers encounter armed and violent
suspects in 2018 the last year for which
such data had been published African
Americans made up 53% of known homicide
offenders in the US and committed about
60% of robberies although they are 13%
of the population
in fact if you actually want to break
down that subset even further you
shouldn't really use 13% of the
population as a substitute because
really you're talking about young black
men it is not black women who are
committing homicide and robbery right
it's a smaller percentage of the
population even than that the police
fatally shot nine unarmed blacks and 19
unarmed whites in 2019 according to the
Washington Post that is down from 38 and
32 in 2015 the post defines unarmed
broadly to include such cases as a
suspect in Newark New Jersey who had a
loaded handgun in his car during a
police chase that guy was still
considered unarmed by the post in 2018
there were 74 hundred black homicide
victims assuming a comparable number of
victims last year those nine unarmed
black victims of police shootings
represent 0.1 percent of all African
Americans killed in 2019
by contrast a police officer is 18 and a
half times more likely to be killed by a
black male than an unarmed black male is
likely to be killed by a police officer
a Memorial Day weekend in Chicago alone
10 African Americans were killed in
drive-by shootings such routine violence
has continued this past weekend 80
Chicagoans were dropped were shot and
drive-by shootings 21 fatally the
victims overwhelmingly black police
shootings are not the reason that black
blacks are dying of homicide at a time
eight times the rate of whites and
Hispanics combined criminal violence is
the latest in a series of studies
undercutting the claim of systemic
police bias was published in August 2000
nineteen in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences the
researchers found that the more
frequently officers encounter violent
suspects from any given racial group the
greater the chance that a member of that
group will be fatally shot by the police
officer there is no significant evidence
of the anti black disparity in the
likelihood of being shot by the police
but 2015 Justice Department analysis of
the Philly Police Department found that
white police officers were less likely
than black or Hispanic officer
to shoot unarmed black suspects
researched by Harvard economist Roland
flaw fryer found no evidence of racial
discrimination in shootings so none of
this matters no because the narrative
must be driven and the easiest way for
the narrative to be driven is to bully
people into into buying the narrative
and to repeating the narrative so
yesterday I drove down Ventura Boulevard
in the valley because there were threats
online that there was gonna be rioting
and looting
in Encino and in Sherman Oaks and I
would say a quarter of the businesses
were boarded up there they're a bunch of
businesses that were born up people had
boarded up their windows so they didn't
want them to be smashed and and rocks
thrown at the windows and I'd say of
those about half of them had BLM
spray-painted on the blacklivesmatter
spray-painted on the plywood or justice
for George Floyd painted on the plywood
or something like that and let's be real
about this do you think that they
spray-painted that on the plywood
because they are destined they're out
joining the protest or do you think they
painted that on the plywood because
they're under the strange misimpression
that people who loop their stores give a
damn about George Floyd or about racial
justice they were attempting to avoid
their store windows being broken you saw
this I saw several of these stores had
signs up on the window ten
minority-owned businesses which by the
way is an unbelievable statement
basically break my don't break my
windows if I'm your race if you are with
another race break the guys next door
windows go ahead and do that hey that
that is immoral it is immoral can you
imagine if they're an anti black right
and people we're putting up the people
were putting up store window signs that
said white owned business that would be
racist by the way the way you know this
is a racist that this is a racially
driven riot is because people are
putting up exactly those kinds of signs
right otherwise the sign wouldn't work
if we were not racially driven then why
are you putting up a race-based sign on
who owns the business the attempt by by
retailers by businesses by corporations
to buy off the mob because this is the
other corollary of this once you've
declared America's racist and
systemically racist once you have gone
to the extent of saying the Target and
Best Buy
that these are just extensions of
American hierarchies of power built on
slavery and Jim Crow once you say all
that there's only one way for those
corporations to get off the schneid so
to speak and that is for them to put out
a Mia culpa
it's for them to say yeah well that made
sure we're part of the American system
but and we agree we agree America is
racist but don't hurt us because we
agree with you we're on your side so we
agree with you so the most pandering of
these statements came from Nordstrom
yesterday so Nordstrom was looted over
at the Grove in Los Angeles Nordstrom
put up a statement on its website quote
the events of this weekend are one more
painful reminder that injustice remains
in the world we can fix the damage to
our stores windows and merchandise can
be replaced we continue to believe as
strongly as ever that tremendous change
is needed to address the issues facing
black people in our country today ah so
in other words keep breaking our windows
because you're doing so in the name of
justice but please don't break our
windows were on your side that's pretty
astonishing stuff
okay I'm sorry woke white people per
involving themselves in performative
virtue signaling so that they will be
left alone online or in their business
I'm not sure how that's great for the
country you're not much you're not
calling for actual changes to policy
you're not backing backing actual change
it's not like well one of these I'd love
to see one of these corporations come
out in favor of ending qualified
immunity I'd like to see one of these
one of these corporations come out small
businesses come out and say you know
what the big problem here is police
unions we need to end police brutality
I'd like to see one of these businesses
come out and say you know one of the
problems here is that we have two little
policing in high crime areas because
that leads to continuing levels of crime
against people of color in these areas
and that makes it very difficult to
invest money in those areas none of
these businesses are gonna say any of
that because that's actual content
instead they're gonna virtue signal with
slogan sloganeering hoping they will be
left alone that's what's happening here
we're gonna buy into the narrative that
blame America writ large
you know what the protesters say that
systemic racism is responsible for all
inequality and then maybe everybody can
get along that's not the way this is
gonna go that's not the way this is
gonna go honestly the best video of the
last 24 hours came courtesy of our
friend Nami Horowitz who's in
Minneapolis and who's in somebody's
apartment building and he took this
video of these appear to be frat bros
who are giving the thumbs-up to
protesters who are on the streets
they're a bunch of protesters who are
walking along the street and these frat
bros start giving the thumbs-up we're on
your side man we're on your side and
five seconds later rocks come smashing
through the window it's pretty hilarious
is it in a very sad and tragic
hilarious but there they are giving the
thumbs up we're on your side man filming
themselves and boom rock comes right
through the window there it goes
yep and we're on you're in the guy
begging and pleading I'm on your side
man we're on your side well that didn't
help did it it didn't help did it we see
this from our late-night host to Jimmy
Fallon is trying to buy his way out of
out of woke Jail so Jimmy Fallon has
been declared unworked for several years
ever since he touched the president
Trump's hair which is apparently the the
font of all evil you're not allowed to
touch president Trump's hair and ruffle
it and treat him like a human being so
Fallon did that a few years ago back in
2016 he has never been let out of wolf
prison since he was leading in the
ratings until then then the media turned
on him and it became time for woke
Prince Jimmy Kimmel and woke Prince
Stephen Colbert to take the lead so
Jimmy Fallon the other night on his show
he apologized for in blackface in 2000
as though this is gonna get him out of
work jail which you will not write but
by the way he didn't wear black face in
the traditional sense of I'm making fun
of black people writ large
he was dressed up as his friend Chris
Rock you know how it wasn't racist you
know how you know it wasn't racist cuz
no one cared in 2000 and turns out
racism was kind of an issue in 2000 I
was there it turns out people cared
about racism in 2000 here's Jimmy Kimmel
apologized for it and then he hosted Don
Lemon because he had to bring on his
black friend to expiate his sins if I
bring on town women one of the worst
commentators in America but he's black
and he's my friend to talk about the
stuff I have listened I have
demonstrated my listening quality here's
Jimmy Jimmy Fallon this story came out
about me on SNL doing an impression of
Chris Rock in blackface and I was
horrified how do I say I love this
person I respect this guy more than I
respect most humans so I thought about
it and I realized that I can't not say
I'm horrified and I'm sorry and I'm
embarrassed and what that small gesture
did for me was break my own silence and
what then I started to do was talk to
some experts some of which are here
tonight and this week and I realized
that the silence is the biggest crime
that white guys like me and the rest of
us are doing it feels like the silence
is not the biggest crime that white
people are doing it seems like the
biggest crime that people are doing is
actual crime and by the
again I'm not sure who thought like the
implication here is that if you do not
sound off on Twitter about every issue
you therefore approve of bad behavior
which is insane I haven't spent a lot of
my time online talking about rape in the
Congo I think it's evil
I think rape in the Congo is evil I
haven't spent a ton of time talking
about because it hasn't been in the news
when it is in the news I'll talk about
it but I don't think that it's safe to
assume that because I have not spent
tons of time talking about rape in the
Congo that means I approve of rape in
the Congo I also do not believe that
because Jimmy Kimmel and Jimmy Fallon
and all the rest of the late-night white
hosts have not spent every day talking
about systemic police racism that they
think the police brutality is okay who
is that like what this implication is
idiotic it's idiotic top to bottom front
to back it's moronic okay all of this is
so much of this is performative and it
can tell so much of this is performative
representative Elliot angles you
Democrat from New York let the cat out
of the bag who's supposed to speak at a
rally and and he was caught on a hot mic
saying you know I wouldn't care about
making a speech in front of this crowd
except that I have a primary coming up
then go down a list and it's just too
many folks
[Music]
so we're arguing over who gets to
posture in front of a crowd for the sake
of voting yeah these are people who take
seriously the problems or alternatively
you know you can as long as you express
sympathy for causes even causes that
like again not not the cause of anti
police brutality the cause of America is
bad as long as you express sympathy for
that you can win some primary votes does
that sound like a way to heal America or
does it really really not okay meanwhile
I have to comment on this because it's
perfectly insane it's perfectly
perfectly insane and it demonstrates
that our pilot our political class
should never be given any sort of power
at all it's absurd absurd okay so
remember that time when coven 19 was a
thing remember that was really that was
kind of a thing right I mean we were
watching our houses from like the middle
of March all the way till now and we
were told that if you go out in public
and you breathe anywhere close to
anybody without a mask you're evil and
you're killing grandma if you talk about
reopening businesses if you can talk
about it you're killing grandma you're
engaging in an experiment in human
sacrifice weird how that all went away
over the last week in that weird if Eric
Garcetti video of Mayor Eric Garcetti
with locked down all of LA County for
months on end all of it
restaurants shut down nail salons shut
down businesses shut down schools shut
down yesterday he had her Mayor
Eric Garcetti out in the middle of a
crowd in his neighborhood with no masks
and people one foot around him by the
way what do you think people do at
rallies do you think that they whisper
to one another six feet apart or do you
think they shout as loudly as possible
expelling huge rooms from their mouths
at every shout the entire rationale for
by the way shutting down churches is
that when people sing very loudly they
expel spittle and that that gets in
other people's orifices and then this
conveys kovat 19 what do you think
protests with tens of thousands of
people do what do you think that does so
you had Eric Garcetti doing that yeah
bill de blasio out in public and Phil
Murphy out in public and every lockdown
advocate in America who's a Democrat out
in public in the middle of large crowds
no masking hugging people weird it's
almost as though I kind of think that
your perspective on Cova 19 was now
bullcrap that you are full of it that
you actually don't think it's that
dangerous by the way you know who you
know who else is picking up on that
signal everyone in Los Angeles I was on
the freeway in LA yesterday
85% of normal traffic and not kidding
over here on like the 405 85 percent of
normal traffic like full-on traffic down
but until the down Ventura Boulevard
because you know what people pick up on
the signal you're not taking it
seriously when you're obviously not
taking it seriously
NPR printed a piece yesterday called
protesting racism versus risking Koba 19
i wouldn't weigh these crises separately
so apparently and then they quote a
suppose it experts in the issue and
saying that protesting protesting racial
inequality is very important cuz racial
inequality kills people but but Kogan 19
also kills people but if you protest
racism you're also stopping köppen 19
amazing amazing so basically if i go out
in a giant crowd and I pray Copa 19 is
gonna get me if I go out there and I
read Torah this weekend with my family
at a shoal Cove in nineteen koban 19 is
and this most evil virus I've ever heard
of Cova 19 hates Jews but here's the
good news
joven 19 loves anti racism loves it
joven 19 will just stop existing as soon
as you're protesting racism so if you go
out there and in some ways it's very
anti-jewish it seems like coca 19 very
anti-christian very anti-jewish but in
other ways Kovan 19 is really super
virtuous and the way that you know pope
19 is really virtuous is that if you
weren't a lockdown protest Kovan 19 was
not alone only going to kill you
it was going to kill your grandmother
you're not associating with but if
you're in a protest that his anti race
American racism copa90 not only will not
kill you you are inoculating yourself to
kovat 19 what an amazing woke virus why
has this not been unleashed on America
before according to this NPR piece ten
thousands of people tens of thousands of
people masked and unmasked have thronged
the streets of Minneapolis Atlanta
Louisville Kentucky and other cities in
the week since George Floyd died after a
white Minneapolis police officer kneeled
on his neck there are the largest public
gatherings in the US since the pandemic
forced widespread shutdowns many local
officials warned of a possible spike in
new cases in one or two weeks dr. Elaine
miss Osie
an assistant professor of global health
at Boston University said risk of
transmission is lower in open spaces but
wherever there's a gathering there is
still the risk of transmitting the virus
health experts urged protesters not to
sing and shout to reduce the threat of
person-to-person transmission the New
York City Department of Health and
Mental Hygiene issued a list of tips for
demonstrators to lower their risk
of contour of contracting kovin 19 and
Washington DC Mayor Muriel Bowser said
she's worried about how consecutive days
of protests could trigger an influx of
kovat 19 cases but according to dozens
of public health and disease experts who
signed an open letter in support of the
protests the risks of congregating
during a global pandemic shouldn't keep
people from protesting racism this is
according to dozens of public health and
disease experts I feel like these
medical experts are like dr. Nick on The
Simpsons
right these are not medical experts okay
they are they they know about about as
much about medicine as my six-year-old
daughter when she puts on her white coat
to dress like mommy they wrote a letter
saying white supremacy is a lethal
public health issue that predates and
contributes to kovat 19 so I'm just
gonna point out here we shut down the
most thriving economy in the history of
the world we put 40 million people out
of work this has we know severe health
consequences we know that if you put
tens of millions of people out of work
you're gonna get an uptick and suicide
you're getting an uptick in domestic
abuse you're gonna get a massive uptick
in drug dependency you're gonna get a
massive uptick in mental illness you're
gonna get a massive uptick in people who
are not going in for their vaccinations
and their surgeries we know all this
because all of this happens to be
factual but if you protest it if you
said hold on there's some health costs
to this copán 19 shut down you are
killing grandma but if you're out there
and you're just shouting that America is
bad and police forces are racist most
solutions nothing that actually levy
it's the problem you just go out there
and you yell a lot about George Floyd
Kovan 19 is solved guys kovin 19 it's
over have you seen the massive crowds in
Europe by the way I do find it
incredible that the crowds in Europe
have so much time to protest about
things happening in the United States
when's the last time you had massive
crowds in the United States protesting
about policy in Great Britain or
something but and I love the Chinese
government intervening here too the
Chinese government like yes we also
oppose racism except for the million we
Gers that we are holding in abject
captivity in our country and the billion
people that we hold in abject forms of
economic repression in our country and
the people of Hong Kong who we hold in
forms of abject repression I definitely
trust the Chinese government on this one
but the these health experts saying that
you can now go protest because we agree
with the protest is insane so this
doctrine Association data is showing the
blacks and Latinos have been
disproportionately affected by over 19
racism is one of the reasons this
disparity exists she said racism is a
social determinants of health it affects
the physical and mental health of blacks
in the United States I wouldn't weigh
these crises separately
okay so put aside the notion that racism
is killing people of kovin 19 which of
course is a bizarre notion are people
being wheeled into the hospital and
doctors are like not taking care of him
he's black get him out of here toss him
in that freezer out back we're done not
seeing a lot of evidence of that but
let's just take it at face value she
says I wouldn't weigh these crises
separately okay so why should we weigh
the the government imposed economic
lockdown that has destroyed tens of
millions of lives separately from the
lockdown itself from covin 19 it's
amazing it's amazing by the way it's the
politicians too so here's what governor
phil murphy said this idiot governor of
new jersey he was asked about the fact
that the protests violated his ban on
large gatherings and here's what he said
quote it's one thing to protest what day
nail salons are opening it's another to
come out and peacefully protest about
somebody who was murdered right before
our eyes
you know what coven 19 doesn't give two
craps about like at all what your cause
is because it's a disease so that was
your entire argument your entire
argument was I can shut down churches
and synagogues and leave certain
businesses open because certain ones are
essential and certain ones are not now
he's just making clear he doesn't like
churches and synagogues and he likes
these protests so he's gonna allow the
protest to go on but he's gonna continue
to shut down churches and synagogues if
that same exact crowd went out and
protested the lockdown very bad shut
them down they're shut they're they're
creating COBIT right there's one wretch
and whitmer the governor of Michigan
said well if you're out protesting you
may spread koban we're gonna have I have
a bigger lockdown now because of that
but if you're protesting racism police
racism in a state run by Democrats then
well you know Cove in nineteen we've
stopped Kovan 19 cold guys I mean this
is good news cover 19 is over we stopped
it victory has been achieved incredible
the worst on this was of course bill de
blasio the idiot mayor of New York who
should be ousted as soon as humanly
possible bill de blasio was specifically
asked by a Jewish newspaper called homo
dia yesterday about the fact that he was
sending cop cars to Williamsburg and
tell people not to congregate for Maariv
that's the evening service for Jews he
really wants they said like a line of
cop cars the tape is available he's in a
line of cop cars in the middle of
Midtown Manhattan being looted and tens
of thousands of protesters being trapped
on the Manhattan Bridge he was he was
sending cop cars to Williamsburg to tell
the Jews don't
Dominion stop going to minion you 10
Jews congregating and praying to God
stop that right now so de Blasio was
asked about this he was asked about this
here was de Blasio's insane and by the
way first amendment violet of answer
when you see a nation entire nation
simultaneously grappling with an
extraordinary crisis seated in 400 years
of American racism I'm sorry that is not
the same question as the understandably
aggrieved store owner or the devout
religious person who wants to go back to
services this is something that's not
about which side of the spectrum you're
on yes it is deep deep American crisis
we have never seen no is about exactly
which side of the spectrum you are on
because you are now declaring it is a
more important American activity to go
out in the streets and shout about
something without any practical
solutions or evidence that this is broad
systemic racism that's more important
than you having a business you having a
way to make a living you putting food on
the table you praying to God right by
the way those those last few things seem
to be at the heart of what most
Americans do every single day and
consider their fundamental freedoms so
it's not important that you go back to
work it's not important that you earn a
living it's not important that you
invest in yourself and your family it's
not important that you go to shul or to
go to church with you go to mosque none
of that's important what's really
important is my daughter getting
arrested in a protest last night that
was truly important activity the real
important activity in American life is
going out and protesting against
miasmatic American racism based on an
incident where all Americans agree the
police brutality took place deeply
important that's important Cova 19 can
have no truck against that kovin 19 the
most virtuous virus ever devised by man
apparently really well done the whoa
kissed virus in the history of the world
or alternatively this is all bullcrap
alternatively it turns out that our
political leaders were not actually
being honest with us
because either they were lying then or
they are lying now either they're lying
about the deadliness of Kovan 19 then in
order to lock us down or they are lying
about the deadliness of koba 19 now in
order to let people out of jail so that
they can go and protest well done
everybody well done everybody problem of
komen 19 solved i'm glad that that this
this whole situation could end with at
least one positive which is that people
can apparently now go out and put i
don't know if i go back to work though
but if but if your work involves you
going out in the street and lying down
on bridge then
I guess you're good to go so solid stuff
there Democratic governors and mayor's
just really really well done all right
we'll be back here later to do two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow and then
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel I
douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup
is by Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright day
Lee Weyer 2020 liberal activists flood
social media with black squares to
support black lives matter and
accomplish nothing the violence
continues and the honest radicals
defendant all the while normal people of
all races get hurt
check it out on the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
you